we've all been told to keep our distance
but for some of those shielding it meant
suffering in silence
it was very depressing as well i would
say because
i'm a single mother with my two children
they're just five and seven but when a
colleague she never met
started checking up on her well-being it
made her feel less alone
it was like a respite for me to have
some form of
adult conversation and you know be able
to
[Music]
open up and share stuff personal stuff
the two women connected through a work
keeping touch scheme
their calls gave support to both of them
i'm so
used to working in a busy office you
know constantly having human interaction
with um colleagues
i was suddenly at home on my own as well
and really missing it
with so many of us feeling so isolated
small acts of inclusion can be a
lifeline
and with many people working from home
or shielding employers say that staying
connected
also makes good business sense national
inclusion week
5 000 companies across the uk are taking
part in the national inclusion week
trying to ensure people don't feel left
behind
if you feel included at work if you feel
part of the community you're going to
perform better
you're going to stay for longer you and
your colleagues are going to be happier
in your work
log down made some reflect on the value
they bring outside of work
the reaching out and the connectivity
with people gives you a
very different perspective when you
particularly when you work for a large
employer and you're very focused on
business
quite rightly but at the same time
there's so much more to life
than achieving just the the business
success the need to stay apart
reinforce the need to stay connected
vassilinovic sky news